[Applause]
also it's very ironic to me when guys
complain about gold diggers because you
know you were the original gold diggers
right you know your
great-great-grandfather's got a bunch of
shovels and started digging up actual
gold
before women were allowed to leave the
house i would love to dig for gold the
old-fashioned way and get like a pickaxe
like a salad strainer
and go get my own gold but you guys took
it all and you refused to share so
now we're gonna have to do this the hard
way
and be in a bad relationship for two
years
and hope that you cheat on me
and i feel like i can say that because i
have had a guy use me for my gold before
and i've noticed when you hear the word
gold digger you always think of a woman
right away men use women for their money
too they're not called gold diggers
they're called like backup dancers do
they have like a
like a jaunty name
it's hard to talk about this stuff
without sounding self-righteous that's
my nightmare i'm trying to not sound
self-righteous about all this because
it's my pet peeve when people are
self-righteous in conversations and i
try to remember though that when
someone's self-righteous it usually just
means they care so much about something
that they become an asshole right i do
it i'm guilty i am guilty i am very into
animal advocacy and oh thank you oh
that's very nice and i don't have kids
what else am i going to do
there are times when i am so passionate
about protecting an innocent animal that
i will be a jerk to a human
it happens
kind of a lot and
recently i saw a stray dog at this huge
intersection in los angeles and nobody
was stopping nobody was stopping so i
pull over and i can see that it's a
little tiny puppy
i know
and i could tell it was in really bad
shape okay so i get out of my car and
this guy yells at him and he's like you
dumb bitch and i was like fuck
you
so i'm like screaming at all these
people and i finally get like 12 lanes
to stop and i get closer to this puppy
and i get closer and closer to this
little tiny puppy and i see that this
little tiny puppy is a trash bag
[Applause]
but i had already been such an asshole
that there was really no turning back at
this point so i just had to
just had to lean in
and that's how i got tetanus
[Laughter]
i am realizing that the guy friends of
mine that are the most self-righteous i
actually think might be the ones that
have done nothing wrong they assume
these women must be exaggerating because
they themselves would never behave the
way they're seeing in the news stories
right like you would never pull your
dick out at work sir of course not
of course not be ridiculous
it would be crazy for you to do that
that'd be an insane thing to do
but
you have that one friend
you can totally see doing that shit
what's his name
jeffrey
anyone that goes by jeffrey instead of
jeff is a fucking asshole
he likes to waste people's time with his
full name
jeffrey that's who we're talking about
right and i try to remind my guy friends
we're not attacking you we just you have
to remember that the world is a little
more dangerous for us because of the
jeffries of the world